I go on social media and the level of
this new toxic self-help out there first
of all everybody's like given like this
life advice and it's just like what is
your life I got to see what your life is
that you've applied this and that it
works are you even a therapist like who
the [__] are you right in the last 30
seconds you just aged 40 seconds
thinking of think about that you know
you know my liver I went to the doctor
my liver I'm 51 my liver is 65 but after
taking this stuff my liver is Now 37 and
I'm 26 my works again and I'm [__]
it's like what is this and I just get
off there going like oh my God I'm a fat
who doesn't spend enough time with this
kid who's uh liver is beyond his age I
want to go back to Old School social
media where it was just watching someone
get kicked in the balls or watching
somebody butcher slashes solo on Sweet
Child of Mine like just somebody getting
shot with a BB gun in the middle of a
river is he screams before his voice
changes remember that one